Sostener los palillos es un poco como sostener un lápiz,
excepto que hay dos palillos
y se los mueve juntos en un movimiento de pinza.
La mayoría son de madera.
También los hay de plástico, bambú, jade, oro, plata e incluso marfil,
aunque creo que eso ya no es tan genial.
Los palillos están muy bien diseñados para comer pequeños trozos.
Son buenos para recoger fideos.
Si eres hábil, puedes comer arroz,
bolas de masa, trozos de carne.
Pero hay cosas que no se debe hacer con los palillos.
No se debe usar los palillos para tocar la batería,
y sé que es tentador.
No se debe poner los palillos en un tazón verticalmente.
Porque, en realidad, eso se asemeja a la forma un cuenco de incienso,
y eso recuerda a la muerte.
Se usan palillos en gran parte del mundo,
en gran parte de Asia.
Unos 1500 millones de personas usan palillos.
Distintas culturas tienen variaciones levemente diferentes de los palillos.
Lo palillos chinos suelen ser largos y redondos,
Los palillos coreanos son más planos y a menudo están hechos de metal,
y los palillos japoneses suelen ser redondos
y muy, muy puntiagudos.
Si bien los palillos son realmente muy comunes
en la sociedad estadounidense de hoy,
definitivamente hubo una época a finales del 1800
donde estaba la idea de que los hombres asiáticos,
dado que comían arroz con palillos,
eran de diferente calidad que los hombres estadounidenses
que comían carne con cuchillo y tenedor.
Pero cuando China y EE.UU.
comenzaron su compromiso diplomático en la década de 1970,
Richard Nixon y Henry Kissinger
tuvieron que practicar comer con palillos.
Es muy interesante ver que,
conforme la cocina asiática pasó de Oriente a Occidente,
los palillos se han vuelto parte de la experiencia.
Hay evidencia de palillos desde la dinastía Shang,
que tiene unos 3000 años.
Durante la dinastía Shang les encantaban los trípodes.
Y si cocinabas con estos grandes trípodes,
los palillos eran realmente útiles,
porque era una forma de revolver y alcanzar
sin quemarse mientras el agua estaba hirviendo
en estas ollas tan grandes.
La cultura china tiene cuchillos y tenedores.
Se los usa en muchos casos para cocinar.
Pero al comedor llegaron los palillos.
Una de las cosas de la cocina asiática
es que a menudo viene en piezas muy pequeñas.
Pienso que parte de eso tiene que ver con el hecho
de que es mucho más eficiente en términos de energía
cocinar trozos pequeños rápidamente.
Pero tampoco es necesario cortarlos.
Entonces hay una influencia circular,
donde el tipo de comida que se cocina permite usar palillos,
y luego el tener palillos influye en la comida que puedes cocinar.
Y al mismo tiempo, los palillos reflejan la naturaleza comunitaria de comer.
Los platos se colocan en el centro,
implica comer en familia.
Uno toma los palillos,
los coloca en el arroz, y luego come solo.
Hay una famosa leyenda
en la que todos tienen palillos muy, muy largos,
tan largos que no podían alimentarse solos.
Por eso en el infierno todos morían de hambre,
porque no lograban recoger la comida y colocarla en la boca.
Y en el cielo, las personas tomaban los mismos palillos
y se alimentaban unos a otros.